hello well to Hollywood royalty here
Brad Pitt standing alongside me on the
red carpet congratulations three
nominations for your film Moneyball she
doesn't only storing but also produced
you're going to have to explain this to
others about baseball wingless just
don't get it just think of it as about
gripping as a backdrop and looking fine
I've better I know very little about
baseball good base it comes about
underdogs it's about people who are
talented but I've been devalued and
getting a second chance it's it's about
how we value ourselves you're in the
same category as your good friend George
Clooney he's already told us he's
prepared to wrestle you to the ground
and fight this out I think we sure I
think you could make a competition I was
just goes on survivor island for me you
know let me put a spoon some obstacle
courses you're saying my name I'm
fascinated problem and obviously some
fantastic company show me shed to go
down as well for the artist howdy rate
his chances in the film I can John
Burton Chancellor really it's wrong you
know I'm happy to see Gary Oldman we
started be all my the old man was still
Toronto matches
we're almost made a big fan so I'd like
to see okay something's here I'm very
beefy I know you spent a lot of time in
London over the summer it's a lot more
wintry now how much does it mean to be
inundated advances I'm sorry I missed
last but don't worry I'm asking you
about London and how much has come to
mean to you and your family you spend a
lot of time here over the past few
months well you know it's a big honor
for us we don't necessarily expect to be
acknowledged so easily it's there's this
great respect here in the arts and it's
great filming here this great great
production value for coming here so just
just to be honored you know this is the
home of Shakespeare's who knows it's a
pleasure pleasure to speak to
congratulations on the nomination there
you go Brad Pitt these feel money ball
is up for three different nominations
here tonight but it's michael fassbender
that he's got his money on in the Best
Actor category